When someone is “blowing smoke up your arse”
today, it is a figure of speech that means
that one person is complimenting another,
insincerely most of the time, in order to
inflate the ego of the individual being flattered.
Back in the late 1700s, however, doctors literally
blew smoke up people’s rectums.
Believe it or not, it was a general mainstream
medical procedure used to, among many other
things, resuscitate people who were otherwise
presumed dead.
In fact, it was such a commonly used resuscitation
method for drowning victims particularly,
that the equipment used in this procedure
was hung alongside certain major waterways,
such as along the River Thames (equipment
courtesy of the Royal Humane Society).
People frequenting waterways were expected
to know the location of this equipment similar
to modern times concerning the location of
defibrillators.
Smoke was blown up the rectum by inserting
a tube.
This tube was connected to a fumigator and
a bellows which when compressed forced smoke
into the rectum.
Sometimes a more direct route to the lungs
was taken by forcing the smoke into the nose
and mouth, but most physicians felt the rectal
method was more effective.
The nicotine in the tobacco was thought to
stimulate the heart to beat stronger and faster,
thus encouraging respiration.
The smoke was also thought to warm the victim
and dry out the person’s insides, removing
excessive moisture.
Tobacco_smoke_enemaSo how did this all get
started?
The Native Americans were known to have used
tobacco in a variety of ways, including treating
various medical ailments, and the European
doctors soon picked up on this and began advocating
it for treatments for everything from headaches
to cancer.
In 1745, Richard Mead was among the first
known Westerners to suggest that administering
tobacco via an enema was an effective way
to resuscitate drowning victims.
By 1774, Doctors William Hawes and Thom­as
Cogan, who practiced medicine in London, formed
The Institution for Affording Immediate Relief
to Persons Apparently Dead From Drowning.
This group later became the Royal Hu­mane
Society.
Back in the 18th century, the society promoted
the resuscitation of drowning people by paying
four guineas (about £450 today by purchasing
power, or $756) to anyone who was able to
successfully revive a drowning victim.
Volunteers within the society soon began using
the latest and greatest method of reviving
such half-drowned individuals, via tobacco
smoke enemas.
Artificial respiration was used if the tobacco
enema did not successfully revive them.
In order that people could easily remember
what to do in these cases, in 1774 Dr. Houlston
published a helpful little rhyme:
Tobacco glyster (enema), breathe and bleed.
Keep warm and rub till you succeed.
And spare no pains for what you do;
May one day be repaid to you.
The practice of using tobacco smoke enemas
on drowning victims quickly spread as a popular
way to introduce tobacco into the body to
treat an array of other medical conditions
including: headaches, hernias, respiratory
ailments and abdominal cramps, among many
other things.
Tobacco enemas were even used to treat typhoid
fever and during cholera outbreaks when patients
were in the final stages of the illnesses.
In their most rudimentary form, tobacco smoke
enemas were not always administered with the
aide of bellows.
Originally, the smoke was blown up the victim’s
rectum with whatever was handy, such as a
smoking pipe.
Of course, such close contact wasn’t ideal
and if the rescuer accidentally inhaled instead
of blew, let’s just say things that one
should not aspirate could be inhaled.
If the person jerked around, mouth contact
was also a risk, even more risky considering
the person being administered too was sometimes
diseased.
In fact, one of the earliest documented references
of using such a tobacco enema to resuscitate
someone came from someone using a smoking
pipe in 1746.
In this case, the man’s wife had nearly
drowned and was unconscious.
It was suggested that an emergency tobacco
enema might revive her, at which point the
husband of the woman took a pipe filled with
burning tobacco, shoved the stem into his
wife’s rectum and then covered the other
end of the pipe with his mouth and blew.
As one would imagine, hot embers of tobacco
being blown up her rectum had the intended
effect and she was, indeed, revived.
This practice quickly spread, reaching its
peak in the early 19th century before, in
1811, English scientist Ben Brodie via animal
testing discovered that nicotine was toxic
to the cardiac system.
Over the next several decades, the popularity
of literally “blowing smoke up someone’s
arse” gradually became a thing of the past.
Figuratively, though, this practice is still
alive and well.